but now i'll be honest the lord is
heading to the magic city
e.t has learned scott disick is looking
to move to miami with girlfriend amelia
hamlin
in tow the party has started we are here
a source tells e.t quote scott's
planning to move to miami temporarily
for a change of scenery and
pace and he will split his time between
there and la
so he can see his kids and the rest of
the family the new details follow scott
and amelia's romantic valentine's day
stroll on
oh how about that a beautiful miami
beach
tune in because you never know what's
going to happen another source tells e.t
that scott's 19-year-old model
girlfriend is planning on moving in with
him
explaining quote scott was lonely when
he and sophia richie broke up
which is one of the reasons he and
amelia got together so quickly
they've been getting a bit more serious
for now scott has been having a good
time with amelia
the 37 year old reality star was first
linked with amelia in november
and they made their romance instagram
official last month
ever since they've been popping up on
each other's social media accounts
i'm never gonna give up my relationship
with courtney and the co-parenting we
have
nothing in a million years will be worth
what we have and i truthfully believe
if the right person were to even come
along into courtney's life
or my life us having children and having
this amazing relationship
would only be a plus to the outsider on
thursday we saw scott get emotional on
the final season premiere
of keeping up with the kardashians gee
goodbye
during a chat with kim and chloe scott
opened up about his previous
relationship with sophia
the pair went their separate ways in
august i thought i would give it a try
and make her more of a priority but then
even when doing that
she was like i don't want to share
you as a boyfriend with courtney
scott says the 22 year old daughter of
lionel richie ultimately reached her
breaking point
and then instead of just wanting to work
with it she literally said with an
ultimatum
you have to choose me or courtney
and i was like but courtney is courtney
and my kids
it's a unit it's a package deal and i
said i was like
how could you even want that for me
sometimes it's time just to cut the cord
yeah like i need to be with somebody
that i trust with
all my heart as for scott's family life
with courtney and their three kids
mason penelope and rayne he says he's
super committed to co-parenting it's a
topic he and courtney's sister khloe
kardashian
candidly addressed while speaking with
et in 2019.
i mean i think you just gotta figure out
really what's important to you at the
end of the day
yeah no i think they're doing amazing
and i think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but
my mom and my dad were like that so we
come from a family where we believe in
that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be
you